good morning good morning
thank you for getting up so early oh no
worries
daniel calls my answer i think this is
our equivalent of like 4 a.m
but uh i think i'm gonna make it worth
your while
that's what i like to hear awesome well
first of all
um i've been seeing you grinding
hundreds of games literally so
good job on that i was happy to see that
how have the three minute games been
going have you been
overwhelmed because they've been looking
better terrible uh
it varies between absolutely abominable
and sometimes
like a steam roll but yeah it's it's
still tough
they have not been clean as i'm sure
you've seen if you checked any of them
oh you i thought you won all of the
games you basically beat acaro on a
smurf account i mean
that's right single leg will run for his
money i did do that
you did it was closer than most of his
games on the speed run but um
so a couple of things i've tried to
select 10 positions that cover a lot of
different topics so we're really going
to try to build
your positional knowledge and we're
going to smooth out the way that you win
winning positions
so i'm going to try to touch all of the
bases through the lens of that drill
sounds great man now this is some
serious [ __ ] here all right dude
i'm pulling the full russian school of
chess on you okay full tilts russian
school of chess and i'm gonna
my uh voice box is uh pretty active this
morning as well
so you better get those right all right
but let's start with a let's start with
maybe one warm-up game
just to [ __ ] wake up and i also need
to drink my coffee so
nothing better than to watch you suffer
while i
[Music]
there will be no suffering here i'm
gonna go nuts
all right this oh he's playing the
exotic dragon
all right it's good e5 is a good move
covering
okay 94. good
man you're like blasting out of the case
like formula one i know this is faster
than i play you're playing well actually
thank you i've played this so many times
now most players play like the exact
same set of [ __ ]
right well a lot of people they who play
the sicilian they play it because they
heard it somewhere
and they don't really study it which is
good knight a4
interesting so you're attacking that
pawn on c5
yeah that was the plan now we're just
gonna chase the knight away or he's
probably gonna take the knight here
all right now he's attacking your e5
bond so think about how you can defend
that
uh i'm i think just pushing the pawn
very good
the best way to defend a pawn is with
another pawn
now is he threatening anything um
[Music]
with his last name basis right
so you really only have one choice you
got there's a piece that you have to
move away
so that b5 is no longer a fork
yeah i think the only piece i can move
away right now is the bishop
bingo you can move it anywhere
okay thank you very
much chris
[Music]
very good man i didn't know you were
this good in the morning oh my god
who was the one who who just woke up
yeah clearly it was chris
chris hvsc man these names really roll
up the tongue is that a bernie sanders
meme photo i think that's just bernie
with the mittens right there
i actually think he plays she actually
plays chess which is funny
um okay uh that was pretty smooth
let's just i have two quick notes on
that game if you don't mind
all right didn't you miss the analysis
board
i know you've been dreaming about it all
these days all these sleepless nights so
very well played in the opening um
couple of nitpicky notes first of all
technically the move castles
uh should have lost upon how can black
win a pawn
hmm i'm assuming it's going to be the e5
pawn
what's defending it yeah he just pushes
up another pawn right at d
d6 so that offers a trade that doesn't
actually win the pawn so what's
defending the e5 knight
just leave high pawn sorry he just takes
my knight and
he takes your knight and takes the punt
and then there's there's a concept that
we'll talk about a little bit later
that's going to help you see
like undefended pieces and pawns a lot
faster but basically he could have done
that so what could you have done here
to reinforce that pawn one more time
just develop the bishop
bingo so you can develop the bishop
there's a this like phrase coined by
grand master
years ago that says bad bishops defend
good pawns
and i actually think yeah grandmaster is
really known for their like poetics
poetic sayings but you can see that this
bishop
is i mean it looks stupid it's just kind
of staring at the pawn but this pawn
is almost like an extension of the
bishop because it's clamping down
on essentially his entire position what
if black tries to play d5 here
just on facade very good so does that
kind of make sense
yeah this bishop may look bad but in
reality it's fulfilling this crucial
duty of
supporting that that pawn okay so the
only other thing
is this idea of knight a4 is a very good
one but you had a much better way to
execute it
oh just bringing it to e4 bringing it to
e4 because in addition to attacking c5
let's say that he would have defended
the pun where else can this knight go
i just go up to d6 and look at this
freaking juicy square i mean
when i look at the square i mean i just
i don't know what to say charlie i'm
tongue-tied you don't understand i don't
get a chance to put knights on squares
like this anymore
grandmasters don't allow this now um i
want you to notice something
this stroke on a what can you tell me
about it uh
well it's got the entire uh light
diagonal open
right and it's undefended right you can
exploit that rook how
um it's a two move sequence that wins a
rook
it's a really nice idea actually
i take knight with knight and then bring
queen up to f3
bingo that's a fork right you attack the
mate
and you attack the rope black has to
defend against the mate very nice
so the the moral here is that when
you're doing something try to do it
through the center
when you center your pieces or you play
through the center
um there's a pretty uh you know that's
that's generally going to be the best
way to go
that's not to say you can never bring
your knights to the rim
and this move actually wasn't that bad
uh but
try to do it through the center if you
can so c3 was great
and then this move bishop e2 makes
complete sense right
taking the sting out of b5 which he
played anyway and you'll see that people
do this all the time if you constantly
focus on preventing your opponent's
threats at your level
uh people can't handle that they'll
they'll like stubbornly put their head
down i wouldn't [ __ ] play b5 okay
give up the pawn very nice uh any
other points in this game that you
wanted to bring up
okay how about one more that was like
yeah so
that was breakfast that was [ __ ]
breakfast
i like the speed
uh oh the famous morally from argentina
i think you should resign now yeah this
guy's kind of scary he's up in the
thousands again
he is this guy
i think was in the 11th century epic on
chess
the check made of morally
alright another sicilian
all right so one more piece to develop
uh i'm thinking just e3 sure
uh that's actually not a great move but
the reason it's not a great move
is something i'll show you after the
game okay
can you open up the center yeah i can
push
d4 that would be a good move because
he's just softened up that knight on c6
so once
he takes and he probably will take on d4
you take with a knight
and you can oh he doesn't okay well
that's a pretty big mistake because what
can you do with that d4 pawn
i can just push it again up to d5 very
nice
do i want to take with the pawn first or
do i want to take bishop
uh either is good but i like taking the
pawn because that chases the knight away
and look carefully at his king there is
a
certain diagonal that you can use to
access this king
but first you can chase the knight away
yeah okay
yeah he can only block check with the
bishop and it's going to be a free
bishop once
right and then a free rock so he's going
to have to move his king basically
yep he can also block with his knight
actually from d7 ah
i didn't even notice he does but now
look at this bishop on b5
you can stick it in further you have an
outpost for that bishop
yeah just a c6 dango and if he takes
then that pawn replaces the bishop and
his pieces are so passive that he's
going to have a very hard time dealing
with that pawn even if you lose that
pawn
uh you'll still benefit can you defend
that pun
yeah i can bring the queen up bingo
excellent
this is this is looking good
he's definitely playing well but you're
in great shape now try to get the queen
back but also keep defending the pawn
yeah just keeping it on e4 here nicely
done
so his best move is to play pawn to d5
okay he castles
now he wants to play pawn to d5 and
sever the connection between your queen
and the pawn can you prevent that move
while bringing another piece into the
game yeah i can just bring over the
ace the a-rook
would it matter which rook i'd bring in
in that position we'll talk about that
the a-rook is the best
and that's an instructive point i've
noted that down
i like that you're asking that question
though that's a that's a big boy
question
it's like a rite of passage the first
time you ask which rook should be on a
particular square okay
so look at which pawns are weakest and
attack them
there's one on one pawn in particular
you're staring at it
yeah it's that the uh c5 if he takes i
win queen
well no but he has the b-pawn defending
it's the d6 pawn the d6 pun is the
backward pawn
can you attack it
uh developing the knight but no um
you see the pawn is on a dark square you
have a dark square bishop
okay big [ __ ]
okay should i take with the rook or the
bishop here well your queen is attacked
so i would move the queen maybe to f5
stay aggressive and
look at that queen it's staring at f7
and h7 what piece could you bring in to
help the queen
begin an attack against his king and you
can do that right now
uh bringing the knight over to jesus yep
and he can't defend both h7 and f7 at
the same time
nice he's probably gonna go queen f6
would be my guess
although i've never predicted anything
ever so
i i imagine i just trade there since i'm
down to 30 seconds
no you'd actually take on h7
because right because that would
basically check me the king
well if he blocks my queen though so i
take with the knight
um so what move okay so he's missed
checkmate in two moves behind it yeah
though it's h7
yeah and then it's just bringing it down
very nice
i think he's probably smashing some
objects in his room right now
she thought that he could flag turbo
fist though very nice
okay so a couple of things to unpack
there
let me invite you
all right
okay so another sicilian you played just
fine now we'll talk about
the proper response of the seal now this
move is a very instructive mistake
and what you need to notice here is this
i've highlighted the bishop of the
knight what can you tell me about them
workable square d4 for a pawn go ahead
and what should black do
um you've already answered the question
now it's a matter of just applying it
yeah so he just pushes here first
exactly and this bishop unfortunately is
it's like the worst possible placement
for these three pieces
yeah and then he takes right bishop
basically has to move
and this is a four black wins a piece
so instead um i would get the bishop
either to f4 to g5
okay probably to g5 and
the thing is this isn't i think maybe
the reason not to put words in your
mouth but maybe the reason you didn't
go to g5 is because they're you're not
pinning the queen right
right but developing isn't you know
i always say this like during the speed
run not every one of your pieces
has to be working on like a kova
distribution plan it's okay for a piece
to just
be sitting on a particular square and
not doing anything in particular it is
doing something it's putting like some
pressure on his position
also it's discouraging him from going d5
why
what happens if he goes d5 here
um well i mean also what i just said was
funny you're supposed to laugh
when a grandmaster makes a joke in there
with covet distribution
well the bishop isn't creating
quotations that was a hilarious
statement
i'm very offended that you didn't laugh
i i am super awkward i think we might
have to discontinue our country just
kidding so what does white do here
uh i think it's i'll give you a chance
to redeem yourself
it starts with taking right and then
it's moving the bishop up
so you take on d5 that's good now think
about this pawn on d5 what is defending
it
just that knight that's right now being
attacked yes so what can we do
what can you do about that night i can
take the knight you can take it
and he's got a choice he can take either
bishop if he takes this bishop what do
you do
uh just take his bishop up there right
yep and then you
do what i pin the queen to the king oh
[ __ ] that's even better than what i
thought
yeah but if he takes with a knife then
what do you do
uh then i
do i bring up my knight to g5
you have a something you can take i just
take the hanging pawn
you take the hanging pawn bingo you have
an extra pawn and finally if he plays
in this position bishop takes f6 then
then i just take the pawn at d5 with
bishop very nice and if he plays bishop
takes c3 to try to
get your bishop what do you do
now an in-between move comes to the
rescue otherwise you'd lose your bishop
hmm so think about your bishop on
defense
take the knight bishop ten out of 10.
you've redeemed yourself
all right our relationship continues
very nice and you're still up upon at
the end of the day
so that's one specific thing the bishop
there does on on
g5 so here you open up the center you go
d5 e takes d5 forces his knight
back to a3 now the reason that you
wouldn't want to give a check first
is because if you notice this pawn on d5
that pawn is very weak so he actually
threatens to capture so first it's
important to get his
his knight back now you go here bishop
c6 so this all made sense
right now um the question of like which
rook to get onto a square i think like
chapters have actually been written
about that specific question
but the rule of thumb is that when you
have two rooks
and you want to decide which one to put
on a particular square
you need to look at the other rook the
one that you're not putting on that
square
and you need to understand whether that
rook is going to have a good spot in the
future
if you put you know let's say you have
x-stroke and y-rook if you put x-rook on
the square in question will rook y then
also have a a decent square so can you
answer that question in terms of rook 81
is this rook going to have a good square
yeah it'll have the e file yeah very
hard question
many choices but what about rook fd1 is
the a rook going to have
prospects it's blocked by all the pawns
and perhaps you could play a4a5 but
you see the relatively big difference in
most cases there's going to be
a clear distinction right if you put one
rook on a square the other
really doesn't have any any good squares
so that's a pretty advanced concept but
i'm i'm happy we talked about it because
you know we're starting to pick up these
small pieces and put them together
great um and the only other thing so
bishop f4
so this move makes sense now right yeah
now after bishop takes c3
um there was an interesting try that you
had an in-between move
what am i talking about
[Music]
and remember why you played bishop f4 it
was taking the pawn and attacking the
queen
bingo okay and
you're now attacking two things now what
would you take the pun with
i'd take the pawn with the rook to
capture the queen but here's something
really really cool
so you're attacking the queen it may
seem that the queen has to move and then
you take the bishop but this is a very
dangerous situation you've got to be
very careful
uh when you're almost putting his pieces
on hold because the queen could move
and threaten something and then you
wouldn't have the capacity to take the
bishop because you have to respond to
the threat
and it may not seem that the queen can
move and threaten something but it
actually can't
can you spot the move it's actually a
really cool tactic
[Music]
is it one move or is it a sequence it's
well it's one move but uh the idea is
revealed on move two basically
okay and the queen doesn't have too many
squares to begin with so you can sort of
yeah use process of elimination
really there's nothing it can do on the
dark tiles here
oh pretty much all of them are covered
well literally all of them are covered
um what i looked at was going c8 and
then coming out to a6
but i don't think that's it yeah that's
like
that's okay but you're going after this
pawn which uh nobody has cared about
since the 16th century so
instead uh the queen
can play a more big boy game look at
white's queen
yeah so it's going to e8 instead right
and it might seem like
okay big [ __ ] i just take the queen and
then i take the bishop but what is black
take on e8 with
uh oh it takes with the knight
bingo and you see what the danger is of
like
uh screwing around when you've got a
hang piece now white is still okay here
why i can play them with rook d8 but i
just wanted to illustrate this notion of
in-between moves you want to look for
them but you want to be very careful
when you're making an in-between move
okay other than that you played
perfectly queen f5 keeping things
aggressive and now night you fight
forking
these two pawns what did you mean when
you were like i would trade queens
which move are you referring to i for
some reason i thought playing
f6 blocked h7 in my oh didn't see it so
i was like oh i have to trade
i see so if you play queen f6 i just
want you to finish the game off and then
we'll move on
yeah it's still the same thing i just
take here okay and now where's the main
now you got to be you got to be very
precise because the king has an escape
escape route via e7 so you got to try to
close that off with tempo
yeah it's taking the rook
right no taking with the bishop but then
bingo but rook is defending the bishop
oh well but he just takes with the queen
right that frees the check i take this
and it continues well you're up a queen
yeah i mean i'm sorry that i was only
able to get you
an extra queen no no i thought i thought
you were okay
i misunderstood i thought i was still
going to get a checkmate somehow but
this is
yeah well you will it's it's checkmate
in another couple of moves
um but and that's actually i'm you know
i'm joking but but it's actually an
important moment when you're going after
checkmate
um sometimes it's a good idea to keep
your mind open
for things that let's say win a queen um
so don't get too fixated on i have to
deliver check with
three moves and then you toss away
options which result in like let's say
an extra queen
so these transformations of the
advantage you always have to keep your
eyes peeled for them particularly if
you're in time pressure
you're not seeing checkmate sometimes
there's like something that may not be
like the computer's best move but still
wins the game
okay makes sense all right perfect um
well done
so now a choice between two incredibly
glamorous things
openings and the drill do you have a
preference for
what we start with hey whatever you're
feeling no preference for me you know
that
okay um let's do openings at the end
since we did a lot of openings last time
and let's go into the drill so
i'm going to give you 10 positions and
you'll quickly see
like how this how this works some of
them are going to be very easy some of
them are going to be challenging
no rush on answering any of the
questions but it would be great if you
could walk me through
your exact thinking process because i'll
be taking uh
obviously like a lot of notes all right
so let's start with the following
position
and hopefully this this works i'm
crossing my nuts
all right let me know if whoops [ __ ] one
sec
yeah we can stick on this position
all right do you see the new position
yeah
perfect so this is from
a game that you were playing as white
against the famous francis seven foo
and uh black played bishop takes g2 yep
and now i'd like you to first to tell me
what the best move is and
that's the way i'm going to do it i'm
not going to tell you what you played to
make it a little bit harder
i think i remember this game i just
moved the rook to e1 if i recall
correctly
that is what you did but uh
i'm pretty sure i lost this game that is
also true
and you had a better move in this
position you're just taking the knight
it's taking the knight and what do you
do now
i just take back the bishop with bishop
yeah or with the rook
without with any piece really and why is
this good for white
um well it's two pieces for one rook
right and a bottom of the light squares
open
exactly so in general if you think about
two pieces for a rook
two bishops is the best combination of
two pieces you could have in the middle
game
um and another rule of thumb
is that the rook is usually better than
two pieces in an end game
because as you can understand when you
have a knight in a bishop they have a
very hard time coordinating if there are
no other pieces
but in conjunction with queens and rooks
the minor pieces usually
are are better because you can see
already the bishop exerting pressure on
h7 if black castles
uh you're going to already have a
battery basically set up how can you
complete that battery
uh i need to get the queen to h
file not necessarily you can
you can put it on a square and thread
and checkmate already
oh just bringing it to g4
how does that threaten checkmate it does
not start and check mate never mind
um
[Applause]
how could you have missed that i i can't
believe i didn't see that
i think you had this h-file idea fixated
in your mind and now
uh i mean this is a pretty serious
threat black doesn't have an easy way to
defend against it if black plays g6
this creates weaknesses on his king's
side what would be the fastest way you
better get this right of involving the
rook in the attack
it's just bringing up the h the f pawn
right f4 and push it again
will you be able to push it to f5
uh well no it doesn't seem like it
doesn't seem like it so
one idea that you haven't this is just
something that's a little nude is to
play king h1 and rook g1
so if the g file is open then
sometimes sliding the king over and then
bringing the rook to g1 is the fastest
way to get the rook
into the attack uh just like file that
away in your in your mind
because that's a pretty that's a pretty
cool attacking idea
good girl so but other than that
the key here is that two bishops in the
middle game usually stronger than a rock
very good next position and you can stop
me at any point if you have questions or
you're unclear
all right um this is against
succulent orange very strong
one of the best games of your career
really although you lost it but we won't
talk about that so in this position you
were playing black so flip the board so
you're facing black
and uh your opponent played the move
knight to b5
now it is your move
try to find the best move for black
okay so i'm gonna mute now this test
charlie's ability to think
prophylactically
white threatens a fork on c7 and there's
no
easy way to defend against the force
because the queen moves will he find it
you have to basically either move the
king or move the rook you have to take
this sting
out of the fork that concept of taking
this thing out of something
is important when charlie just allowed
the bishop to
a6 pinning the knight to the bishop if
the knight moves i take bishop
he takes with queen i take knight
deliver a check and then win a rook
okay so you just said a lot of [ __ ] and
very little of it was correct
so perfect after bishop a6
first of all you said that pins the
bishop so that doesn't actually pin the
bishop because white's bishop is
defended
yeah so a pin is something where
if the piece that is pinned moves then
you win
the piece that is on the other end of
the pin i guess i was just thinking too
long term so
but also what is white going to do here
did you ask yourself what white's threat
was
no i didn't oh he was just the only
thing i saw was just threatening the
check on d6 but i mean i heard yeah d6
but i don't see what that would win
it wouldn't well there's another check
that then
jesus c7 that's right don't make me
don't make me make you solve those fork
problems again and after king d8
you've actually given white an
all-you-can-eat buffet he can even take
the bishop if he wants
or what what else can he take the rook
of course you can take the rook so
coming back to the starting position
try to find black's defense here and
there are several
decent moves none of them are glamorous
but you have to find a way to defend
against the fork
the eight king yeah so king d8 is one
move you could also go at it from the
other end
like you can move either the king or
the rook v8 and this would be marginally
better because it does pressure the
knight a little bit
you could even defend the square by
going queen a5 but this is not a great
idea because remember
um you know you don't want your queen
basically fulfilling this very menial
task you want your queen
doing more important stuff so this is
prophylaxis
a rook b is prophylaxis and uh you've
got to get back into the habit
especially when there is a move that
occurs
in your quadrant of the board that's a
very
rough but i think a good rule of thumb
you should particularly be alert to
those moves because they are more likely
to create threats
uh i think that you i didn't record what
you actually played but you allowed
uh you allowed the fork and uh he won
the rook and
there was some back and forth that
happened afterwards but
if you just move the rook you'd be
winning here
clear all right
now the next one is going to be a
slightly different structure
i'm going to tell you the move that you
played i'd like you to tell me if this
move is good or bad
and uh explain so you played the move
knight c2 in this position
back anything uh i think it's a strong
did not eventually get anything out of
it he just drops the queen back i have
nowhere to go and i still don't take
anything so
bad wait a minute if he drops the queen
back
i think the rook he has to move first
than the queen right that's what you
said initially of course
and uh what's wrong with the placement
of the knight
it just doesn't attack anything once the
rook moves and i have nowhere to go
you have nowhere to go that's the more
important part is trapped so where would
you go
instead of going c2 um
i guess just drop it back right to bring
it over to like d5
exactly and here's the interesting thing
you actually went on the previous move
knight d5 to b4
and then your opponent plays e3 and my
old coach
would call this saying sorry it's when
you make a move
and uh you know your opponent responds
to that move and then you realize that
you played a really shitty move
often times just bringing the piece back
to its the square that it came from
is the much better option but often we
stubbornly go for the plan
that we had initially created even if we
kind of know deep inside that it's bad
right so maybe you thought that knight
c2 was a fork
um but remember that if you play a move
if you realize oh [ __ ] you know i [ __ ]
up which which never happens i mean you
never you never do that
this is for like you know this is for
for
mere mortals uh you can always or not
you can't always do this but you can
sometimes
bring your piece back to where it came
from and uh that's the much better
the lesser evil so knight d5
and also be very careful about your
pieces getting trapped within
your opponent's territory now if i did
let's say i still played that move like
absolutely what would be a decent
follow-up i
the only thing i saw was like maybe
moving queen a5 attack that pawn
he like drops his queen back i i don't
know
which fun does this attack just oh never
mind bishop pressures it pressures the
pun but it doesn't exactly now actually
i
i spent some time thinking about and i
gave myself a little bit of a challenge
would i be able to find a way to
extricate the night
and unfortunately like i came up pretty
dry
um you actually played an interesting
move although i don't know if your
intention was
to do what i'm about to show you you
played rook b8
and unfortunately your your opponent
played bishop e3 which is correct it's
the only way to trap the knight
if he had moved his queen back to attack
the knight you would have been able to
get the knight out how
remember so rook b8 what does that move
do
it creates an x-ray yeah it's looking at
the rook
through the pawn at b2 so oh it makes i
it's just bringing the knight over to a3
bingo and again
undefended pieces are so important here
and
uh x-rays are going to come up again
they are incredibly important
um whenever any set of pieces are on the
same file or if it's bishops on the same
diagonal
no matter how many pieces are between
them you have to pay attention to that
because
that kind of [ __ ] it it often leads to
tactics
a lot faster than somebody might think
good
so knight back to d5 preserves the extra
piece this game from a sicilian by the
way so you got a great position
all right problem number five
and i know this is a bit tedious but
hopefully it'll pay off in the end now
uh face white you were playing white
here
against um grover diem another another
very famous player
and once again i'm going to tell you the
move that you played and i'd like you to
tell me if that move
is good or bad and then propose an
alternative if it's at hint it's bad
why is it bad you play g4
so first why is the move bad uh it hangs
my
n well it doesn't hang my knight nothing
was defending it to begin with but uh
well my knight's undefended at h4
uh the pawn again he can just drop the
bishop
back to like f7 to get it away from any
danger
well you started well but then you
trailed
trailed into the wrong direction you
said the knight is undefended right
let's expand that for a second is
anything staring at the knight
the bishop at e7 that's another x-ray
and x-rays
are it's like they what is that [ __ ]
called
when it turns into a butt a butterfly
caterpillar
no but before the caterpillar morpheus
metamorphosis right
but that's the process through which it
turns but like there's that
caterpillar but before the caterpillar
it's like a larvae it's a larva
okay so if x-ray is the larvae then
discovered attacks are the butterfly
when you see an x-ray you need to
understand that that may blossom into a
butterfly so
now that i've spun this beautiful
analogy you definitely will find the
move
yeah he just takes the pawn right and
then that uh
he if i take his knight he just takes
no yep go ahead that's absolutely right
so can you make the move
very nice now what what may have
deterred you is the fact that you're
attacking his bishop
but calculate further what happens after
why can't it's jack that's actually what
happened and
the the problem here isn't only that you
lose a pawn it's that your king
has to get out and you understand that
that's pretty disastrous in the middle
game
right it's not that bad but nonetheless
how could you have
ensured that this doesn't ever become a
problem
that's why knights on the rim can be can
be bad
were you going to say grim rim yes but i
decided you know
to avoid the cliche or dim
the british say knights on the rim are
dim
i could just castle at this point but
could could you
not make me nervous with this knight i
could just bring the bishop to f2
but why aren't you moving the knight are
you like
attached to the hip to the h4 square i
just don't see a good square for it if i
bring it over to
open your eyes yeah that's the square
that's a good square for it is there
anything wrong with it
no i guess not it i think it's a very
sexy square actually
but you know i may be wrong but you're
attacking g7
it's sometimes called knife f5 can he
castle
like literally the bishops illegal
so believe it or not black actually has
a really hard time defending this pawn
he can't play rook g8 your bishop's
attacking the rook so
you can't just push up the pawn and
chase the knight away well the knight's
then going to go to g7
and where's the king gonna go if the
king goes to f8 then what happens
oh i deliver a check at e6 and i win the
queen
very nice now if the king goes up to d7
then you've already accomplished a lot
now you can actually win one of his
pieces
through a move that you did play in the
game but now this move is actually very
strong
look at his bishop on h5
just pushing the pawn up here absolutely
you sound surprised
yeah i i was looking at a check on the
either b5 or
e6 well e6 would be a really good move
actually also this would go for
checkmate which would be legitimate now
you could try to open the center you
actually oh that's a sexy checkmate
you're threatening a mate with d5
that's really cool actually well he
takes with the knight and then you take
with trevor because this bishop is gonna
stop the king's escape to b6
but maybe black can try to like somehow
escape
so this would be very much possible but
g4 would be the gritty approach
i think the fact that i haven't had
breakfast is reflecting in my
suggestions you know
but it makes sense that this straps the
bishop and the knight has this escape
square on e6
so that's the difference between the
previous position in this position it's
okay to bring
one of your pieces into your opponent's
territory if
either you you can chart an escape
route for that piece or that piece is
indispensable
to an attack like you may eventually
want to sacrifice this knight
but the knights serve the greater good
of getting the king out into the open
right makes sense to me great
so knight f5 would actually have been a
very good square and always
look for the x-rays if you have an
undefended piece and your opponent is
staring at that piece even if it's
through
another one of his pieces you've got to
start looking for those discovered
attacks
nice okay now the next one is going to
be one of your favorites
one of your old favorites now
you were playing black in this position
i think i lost on time here
you did so i am going to
force you to win this position without
now what you did is
i mean you actually tried to promote
this pawn you for some reason made a
knight
with that pawn oh this was during the
tournament yeah for some reason i
clicked queen but it made a knight
well here's the hilarious thing i've
actually done that a couple of times
where when you're trying to really
quickly promote it's easy to
accidentally click the knight
no it was a glitch with chess it was a
glitch okay
well so was your face but um that was a
low blow sorry but i want you to win
this position
as quickly as you can without touching
the same pawn
yeah i imagine it starts here and then i
just get the queen over well is that the
best one to take
oh i just take this one first yep
uh
why are you taking that pawn does
anybody give a single damn about that
pawn
because i don't really oh i guess i go
here no that doesn't work that's a great
move
that's a good [ __ ] that's a great
move because the rook is untouchable
now how do i finish it though you can do
that but why don't you attack that g2
pawn
oh do it with the rook instead yeah okay
and then
no matter what he does bingo
four moves now you could also rook f3 is
a fancy move but you could how else
could you get the rook onto a square
such that it attacks g2
without lifting it through the f file
find an alternate route for me
so without doing a rook lift i want to
get it with that real
well not to the g file but to a square
where it attacks
okay
then the only thing i see is just
dropping it and then going up so just
like maybe i was hoping like
e8 and then push that's exactly what i
was thinking nice
so e8 e2 and then we take g2 so
uh you've been doing a much better job
than you did earlier at winning winning
position
but um what i'm seeing is that you
sometimes try to take all of your
opponent's pawns
or you try to promote like 18 queens
before you actually start checkmating
him
if you have a queen and a rook and he
has only pawns
that is enough material to give
checkmate and it's usually going to be
inefficient
to try to promote another queen